الان الينا من رام الله شعوان جبارين مدير
مؤسسه الحق لحقوق الانسان اهلا بك سيد
شعوان في الواقع يعني هذه المشاهد
نتابعها وكنا قبل دقائق فقط استمعنا الى
هرسي هاليفي رئيس اركان الجيش الاسرائيلي
وهو يتحدث عن العمل المهني لجيشه وانت
تتابع هذه الصور ما
تعليقك
اولا هذا جيش مستعمر لا يمت لاي ص باي شرف
عسكري واي قيم انسانيه ما يقولون عنه انه
هذا جيش
اخلاقي واحيانا يتبجحون بانه الاكثر
اخلاقيه انا اقول انه الجيش الاكثر
انحطاطا في العالم ما نشاهده
وشاهدناه ولاحقا
سيتكفل عندما نلتقي الضحايا وشه وود
العيان على هذه الجرائم بانه من الحرب
العالميه الثانيه وحتى الان لم يحدث في اي
مكان بالعالم هذا النوع من الجرائم وهذا
الاتساع وهذا العدد وبهذه الطريقه وفي هذا
المكان ومكثف بهذا الزمن هذه جرائم تعكس
طبيعه هذا المستعمر تعكس ايديولوجيه تعكس
قيمه التي لا تمت للانسانيه بصله هذا هو
واقع الحال
ولذلك انا برايي الان هو ينكشف امام
العالم شعبنا انكشف امامه بعام في 48 وما
قبل 48 وبعد ال 48 بمذابح وبم جازر وبتنك
وباغت اساب واحيانا كانوا يتباهون بعض
ضباط وجنود هذا
الاحتلال في الطنطوره على سبيل المثال
وغيرها ولكن الايام هذه تختلف الامر بوجود
كاميرات وجود نعم هذا هو الفارق ربما في
هذه الحوادث التي اشرت
اليها نعم هذا هذه الحوادث التي اشرت
اليها في 48 وما تلاها تحدث عنها ضباط
اسرائيليون فيما بعد وقضيه التحكم
والسخريه وال حجم الجرائم لا نعرفه الا من
خلال شهاداتهم هم لاننا لم نكن نملك الصور
ولكن الان نملك الصور هذه الصور وليست
المره الاولى التي نشاهد فيها
فلسطينيين يعرون بهذه الطريقه ولكن اول
مره ربما نشاهد هذا العدد منهم داخل ملعب
وبينهم نساء واطفال بينهم حتى
رضيع هؤلاء لا يميزون هذا الاحتلال يرتكب
جريمه اباده جماعيه بحق الشعب
الفلسطيني الامر لا يهم اذا كان طفلا او
شيخا او امراه او مريضا او طبيبا او عامل
اي صحي
ومهني زي الهلال الاحمر او غيره هذا لا
يهم اي شيء لا قصدت قصدت في سؤالي
والفلسطيني مستهدف وجودا استاذ شعوان قصدت
بسؤالي انهج يبيع يبيع العالم الغربي يبيع
الغرب قصه انه يركز على من يشكل خطرا عليه
ويصر يعني على ان من ينكل به هم من وجهه
في نظرهم هم الارهابيون ولكن ما نشاهده
ويشاهده العالم في هذا الملعب لا يمكن
لطفل رضيع ان يكون
ارهابيا فما الذي يمكن ان يكون تاثير مثل
هذه الصور فعلا في الميدان الحقوقي في كيف
يمكن ان
تستعمل من اجل فعلا ان تحدث فارقا هذه
المره بصراحه هي صوره ذاتها تحدث فارقا
الان على مستوى من له احساس وانسان وله
قيم انسانيه وهناك احساس كبير عند الشعوب
ولكن المسؤولين الغربيين امريكا بالمقام
الاول مسؤوليها وادارتها من رئيسها الى
وزير دفاعها الى وزير خارجيتها والطواقم
العامله والتي تتعاون الان وتدير الحرب
هذه ليس لها ايه مشاعر انسانيه ولا تقف في
المربع الانساني والى جانب الانسانيه في
التاريخ هذا موضوع منتهي سواء شاهدوا هذه
المناظر او لم يشاهدوها لاحظوها او لم
يلاحظو سمعوا بها او لم يسمعوا بها ولكن
انا برايي تحدث فارقا على مستوى العالم
الان وعلى مستوى الراي العام العالمي وهذه
مساله مهمه ومهمه جدا الشيء الثاني قد
ياتي سؤال ويقول ماذا يشكل هذا الامر وهذا
التنكيل وهذا التعذيب وهذا المساس
بالكرامه الانسانيه هذه م مسائل
يعني لم تحدث لم لا يمكن ان نتصورها
نهائيا يعني بالعصر الحديث يمكن ان لا
نتوقع مثل هذا الامر ولكن هذا يحدث بشكل
يومي على مستوى الجريمه هي تعتبر ليس
عقوبات جماعيه فقط هي تعتبر جريمه ضد
الانسانيه هذه تاتي في اطار سياسه مراسلكم
قال ومعلوماتنا التي نوثقها تقول والواقع
يقول انها تحدث بشكل يومي واينما وجد قوات
للاحتلال يحتكوا بالمدنيين هذا ما يقومون
به الشيء الثاني حجم الجريمه التي ارتكبت
بسبعه شهر وثمانيه شهر وما بعد ذلك
للمدنيين الذين دخلوا خلف الجدار ولل
المقاومين الذين دخلوا لا يوجد حتى الان
صوره وروايه واضحه من امسك بهم وقتلوا
واعدموا ميدانيا من يعتقل الان ويموت يقول
يتوفوا ماذا يتوفوا هذا يتوفوا من التعذيب
هذا يتوفوا من اطلاق النار والقتل لذلك
هناك صور عديده لم تتضح بعد انا برايي
عندما تن تنقشع تنقشع غبار المعركه سنكتشف
هناك حجم الجرائم المرتكبه الاحتلال لا
يقوم بذلك يعني نتيجه هذا الجندي او هذا
الضابط نز نزوع اجرام لا لا لا هذه ضمن
سياسه رسميه عندما يقول رئيس الدوله
بتصريحاته بالايام الاولى انه لا يوجد
مدنيين ابرياء بغزه هذا واضح وضوح الشمس
عندما يقول
وزير دفاع او وزير حرب المستعمر بانه اي
نحن نقاتل اي وحوش بشريه ويتعامل مع
الفلسطينيين كوحش ويقول سنقطع الماء
والكهرباء والغذاء ويقومون بذلك هذا هو
واقع الح هؤلاء وحوش هؤلاء مجرمين العصر
هذه هي المساله العصر او التاريخ يعيد
نفسه كان المره الاولى في الحرب العالميه
الثانيه والان يعيد نفسه مره اخرى وهذه
الرساله التي قلناها لجميع العالم ونقولها
لا نرجوكم الا تجعلوا التاريخ يعيد نفسه
ولكن الان يعيد نفسه وبشكل اقصى واكثر
وحشيه واكثر ايلا
ولكن هذه هي حقيقه وطبيعه هذا المستعمر
هذا المستعمر هي طبيعته الذي لا يريد لا
لطفل ولا لمريض ولا لشيخ ولا لمراه ولا
لاي حدا من الفلسطينيين ان يبقى ولكن
سنبقى هذه بلادنا نحن سكانها الاصليين
سنستمر فيها والحجاره ستقاتل معنا في يوم
ما اشكرك شعوان جبارين مدير مؤسسه الحق
لحقوق الانسان من رام الله شكرا جزيلا